Three
two
one
GO!
We hosted
the world's first
ping pong
bounce contest
and the last person
to drop their ball
WINS $1000!
First one is out!
Oh, you're out!
Oh, no!
There’s another one!
Oh no!
You can do it!
Noooo!
It's my
personal best!
Three players
have already been
eliminated!
The atmosphere is
very concentrated
Are you confident?
I'm pretty sure
I’m gonna  win!
But it's
It’s surprisingly
You have to focus!
You’re going to hear this sound for
a week after this
What happened?
I was thinking
what I will do
with the prize money
But...
now I’ll never know
People were
dropping out
one by one
but we will start
giving them
different
distractions
so the longer
they bounce
the harder it gets!
Good effort!
Just...
popped my finger!
I feel like I'm
starting to get
good at this!
And before
things get
more exciting
we want to show you
today's sponsor
Wondershare Filmora!
We have been editing videos
for several years
and have to say
Filmora is
one of the most
beginner friendly editing softwares
out there!
Literally,
anybody can start
using it
even with zero
editing skills!
And it has so many
different functions!
For example
these built in
animations
took just a few minutes
to add to this video
to make a super cool edit!
There are loads of
built in templates
like texts,
overlays, filters
to help you
edit videos
quickly!
Ooooh!
Thank you very much!
Thank you
Wondershare Filmora
is also more budget friendly
compared to many other
editing softwares
Went for a
evening stroll
and I lost
the ball!
gg
gg!
Thank you!
Players are
dropping out
like flies!
We haven't even introduced
the special rules!
The best
thing about Filmora
is how easy
they’ve made it to
add advanced edits
to your video!
For example
the Speedramping
feature
is just a simple tool
that will get you
a clean
professional edit!
Some other
features like this
are the super easy to use
motion tracking feature
and a
massive library
of different
effects
and transitions!
You can also make
these same edits
if you try
Filmora’s
free trial!
It will create
a watermark
on the video
but make sure
you follow them
on Instagram
and comment
to have a chance
to win
a free license!
Huge thanks
to Filmora
for sponsoring
this contest!
Let’s go see how
they're doing!
Ooh tricky one!
Do one
really high one!
Yeah!
Don't fall for it!
He’s good!
I’m buying everybody pizza
if I win
You're counting
to 100
I have done
like four times
hundred!
Okay
so six minutes gone
and we're at 400
bounces
How's it going
over here?
Focused
dancing in my mind
This should be an
Olympic sport
This one is
the most relaxed
I think
He's out!
I see some dance
moves!
It's almost easier
if I don't focus
on this too much!
You really think so?
Well it's going
pretty well man!
How is it going?
It's quite good but
I feel very
hypnotized
There's some
people saying
there was some
sketchy ball
changing actions here
Is that true?
it was that
boy here
It wasn't me!
We are
we are showing
currently footage
of the illegal
movement here
I don’t believe you!
I want to see
the footage!
He's running away!
I was set up!
That would be nice
if you come to trainings
to get new players
Yeah!
I love it!
Friends being made
during the
tournament!
This is lovely!
And if you want to do
something lovely today
You can click subscribe
to help us reach
5 million suscribers
It's not as easy
as you think!
No!
You need to focus
a lot!
It's more of a
mental exercise!
Don't mind me
you're doing great!
Thank you!
I can
watch the camera
all the time
if you want
Yeah!
You can do that
We have a challenge
for you
If you can do
a behind the back
we will give
you 50€
Whenever
you're ready!
And he got it!
Very impressive!
This guy just won
himself 50€!
So we'll just
you know i’ll...
I don't have
any pockets!
Just keep...
OH!
He dropped it!
It's okay!
Well, here you go!
Thank you!
At least
you got 50€
That’s good!
You just go...
Bounce,
bounce, bounce
behind the back
and continue!
50€
Come on, do it!
Okay, I will do it
Okay, let's go!
Oh, nooooo!
That was so close!
He went for it!
Samuli you wanna try
that also?
No
We've had a dropper!
There's one
less player!
Bad touch
bad touch
My favorite
contestant!
I lost focus
But I still feel
really good about this!
Feel like I won myself!
That's the most
important thing!
Oh we’ve got
another drop out!
I had to go out
because it would have been
unfair for the others
Yeah of course!
Of course
Try one
Backhand bounce
Was that 50€?
No it wasn't 50€
that one!
So we have 12 players left
and it's
25 minutes gone!
We're coming up with some
sneaky challenges
to make
it more difficult!
Okay guys
when I say go
you need to
sit down!
and then come
back up!
The last person
to get up on
their feet
gets eliminated!
Go!
He's keeping it!
What a save!
We got one out!
We got one out
Nice try!
Thank you!
We don't
even have to check
the replay
who was last
because we already
have an elimination
We got the one out
11 players left!
Okay
we'll let you relax
for a bit!
Just for a bit
You think you're
going to make it?
I would like
to go to sleep now
I'm starting to
get a little hungry
Do you have
any snacks?
Yeah
we can bring
you some snacks!
We have a hungry
contestant
so we will
bring them food!
You look a
bit bored!
Ooh!
We've got
another drop out!
Noo!
My eyes were tired
and then
I lost my focus
It happens!
Sometimes
Like I have
the cramps
in my hand
Yeah! Same, same
Actually
I have tried it
a few years back
and I got 30 minutes!
13?
30 minutes!
No, another one!
Yeah
because I speak
with guy
So someone was
flirting with you
and you got
distracted?
Yeah...
What a cheeky move!
My guy here
went to flirt
with the girls
and she got distracted!
I’m so sorry!
I'm sorry!
And he dropped it!
Noo!
but now
you can go and
talk to her
nobody is going to disturb you
Banana delivery!
She's got
the banana!
Miikka
where's my pizza?
Let’s make the
circle smaller
Yeah
This one is going to be
an easy one
We're just making the
circle smaller
Just like
in Fortnite
Yeah!
Down to eight people!
We have a suggestion
for you guys!
The next person
to drop their ball
will get €50
The person
after that
won't get anything!
If you don't think
you're going to win it
now could be a chance
to at least
take home 50€
Nobody went for it!
Let's try this one
add another 50
So hundred euros!
Oh she dropped it!
she dropped it
Hundred euros
and a banana!
That's very good!
Okay so we're down to
to seven contestants!
Otto they’ve been
going at it for 45 minutes!
Yeah
He's in the zone!
What is your favorite color?
I’m guessing yellow...
Who's your favourite
table tennis player?
Good answer!
Thanks for the
thanks for
the words
we will
wish you all the luck!
We couldn't
break him!
Oh dear!
Should have taken the 100€
Yeah
you had a chance
This is my
personal favorite!
Requires
some teamwork
It requires
strategy!
And
it requires trust!
First
you need to pick
a pair!
Team number one
attempting
the ball switch!
Team number one
clears
the challenge!
Time for
team number two!
That was
super impressive!
Three!
How does it feel?
So dissappointed
Think he did that
on purpose?
I'm quite
sure he did!
Bad communication
from my side
If I win
I will give him
25%
Okay
Team number three!
It wasn't
an easy one
You made it for
exactly
one hour!
I'm glad that this
human exam is over
Bit underwhelming!
didn't work!
these guys
are solid!
Can you
keep going for
another hour?
Do you think?
Yeah
but it's just
boring!
It's boring
you heard Sam
Otto!
We've got to make
some changes!
Thanks Sam!
For the next
30 seconds
you have to lift
your leg!
Ready, set, go!
keep going
Samuli keep going!
Three
two
one
and normal
Samuli’s sitting down
of course!
Nobody dropped out!
Let's go
think of something!
Just so me
and Otto wouldn't
be the ones
deciding
who gets through
We have brought two
neutral players
who have
dropped out earlier
Their fate is
in your hands!
Oh, god!
Now it's time
to slowly
gather yourselves
around
the three seats
behind you!
Oh my god!
Now you can answer
what is your favorite color?
Yellow, right?
Yeah
It's yellow!
We got it!
That means
one chair less
for the musical chairs!
Oh no!
So we
are the final three!
What are you going
to do
with the thousand
euros if you win it?
I’ll buy the Sensei racket
Buy Sensei racket!
Very good!
You heard it
from Samuli!
that's a very
good investment!
all the way
from Norway!
Yeah!
He's got
the Pongfinity
Sensei racket
That's the secret
to victory!
I trust you
I want you to win!
Yeah!
I think
Final three
Next phase
musical chairs!
Sam is
just eagerly
waiting!
Okay!
Ready, set,
GO!
I'm so
nervous myself!
We have
Sam!
The only one
sitting on
the chair!
Winning 1000€
Woooh!
He got it!
It's turned purple!
Exactly one hour
30 minutes
Congratulations!
Congrats!
Thanks for watching
until next time!
Thank you
everybody
for coming!